so there is a lot of talk right now
regarding this mysterious villain that's
supposed to pop up in Avengers 4 there's
a lot of theories circulating around
that right now I've proposed some of
them myself but I think the general
belief right now what the fandom is that
it's Annihilus and his army the
annihilation wave quick heads up my
giveaway still continues if you'd like
to enter for your chance to win a copy
of Avengers infinity war or ant-man and
the lost spawn blu-ray and some special
edition posters all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero there's a lot of
backing to how it could make sense that
Annihilus is the second villain in
Avengers 4 but I think that the fandom
mainly believes that it's going to be a
nihilist because it's believed that the
Avengers 4 title is Avengers
annihilation but Annihilus is sort of an
underpowered enemy
Thanos defeated the Avengers no problem
and I personally believe that Thanos
could kick a nihilist his butt as well
and the leaked description that we read
stated that there's going to be an even
greater threat so this second mysterious
villain has to be stronger than thin O's
so who could be a greater threat than
Thanos that they could bring on-screen
but will also not be too overwhelming
for people who aren't diehard fans like
us because introducing characters such
as The Living Tribunal and Eternity
although I would love to see it and can
see how it would work in the movie I
think it may be a little too much so who
could this be
it could very well be Galactus and I
know the first thought that pops into
your head is Disney does not own the
rights to Galactus it can't be Galactus
and I'd hear you
but what if Disney and Fox worked out
some sort of deal to where Galactus
could actually be in Avengers 4 it's
certainly possible that they did
remember these two little movies called
Deadpool and guardians of the galaxy vol
2 well Marvel and Fox actually worked
out a deal to swap the rights to
characters for these two movies Marvel
allowed Fox to use negasonic teenage
warhead in Deadpool and change her
powers while Fox allowed Marvel to use
ego the Living Planet and guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 but what if other deals
were made what if they actually worked
out a deal to use Galactus and event
for Avengers infinity war and Avengers 4
had been in development for a long time
and you know how Marvel is they think
everything out remember how they trolled
us with Avengers infinity war trailers
editing scenes to make them different
for the trailer than they are in the
movie and putting scenes in the trailers
that weren't even in the movies at all
they think things through the Russo
brothers also mentioned that there's
going to be new characters and Avengers
Ford that we've seen in the comics but
have never seen in the MCU well in the
comics Thanos performs his snap and
eventually the cosmic beans show up
requesting that he surrendered the
Infinity stones because they deem him to
be too powerful Galactus devourer of
worlds is front and center in this
battle I think that Galactus is who
everyone wants to see more than any
other character enter the MCU and I
think he's the perfect character to
bring into Avengers 4 as another villain
the Russo brothers have stated that we
have no idea what to expect for Avengers
4 well we probably don't expect Galactus
to be an Avengers 4 because Marvel
doesn't own the rights to him Fox does
but seeing as how Avengers 4 is going to
be probably one of the biggest movies of
all time they're going to need one of
the biggest baddest characters of all
time especially if you're going to try
and top fan OHS and Marvel and Disney
know this they struck a deal for
Deadpool and guardians of the galaxy vol
2 so there's no reason that they
couldn't strike another deal with them
this time for the rights to Galactus and
with the Disney Fox deal going through
Galactus is coming home to Marvel
anyways so Fox can only really win by
letting Marvel use Galactus in the MCU
they're going to lose him anyways they
might as well get something for it and
it would make everybody extremely happy
so don't think that Galactus can't be in
Avengers 4 just because Fox owns the
right to Galactus they could have very
well worked out a deal with Marvel but
let me know what you all think of this
do you think we'll see Galactus and
Avengers 4 or do you think there could
be a better villain than him let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video for your chance to win
the giveaway and so you can stay up to
date with everything relating to
Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]